[Music]  all the way Rove one introduces Star  Wars fans to a whole new crop of  characters but come on there is one that  wholeheartedly deserves a round of  applause congratulations you are being  rescued if you could describe k2 in one  word what would it be genuine love good  guy k2s though the bluntest arguably  sassiest droid in the galaxy it played  by the incomparable alan tudyk who I  spoke with over the summer at Star Wars  Celebration he's a essentially I grumpy  old man he's yes and we're between that  and a child 7 foot 1 inch tall  he's sassy it sounds like there is  happening he's genuine and honest to his  perception why does she get a blaster  and I don't really gonna be the  convention I'll be the convention guy  signing autographs even when people like  who's that what's that sad old man in  the corner no hay - he's gonna be a star  you're right that's k2s oh come on yeah  you